Jeff malene wife can wiping husband I'll
take your the fire I might not be done
by then I should misbehave more often
we're being followed
how the hell are you Anna this work keep
you safe then I will
first long as we both shall live
good morning wife
come on a nose man
don't ask me this is great
look at your window why you know I'm
taking you away for the weekend I just
can't believe this was my life that I
get to live with you
roses her
that meant nothing to me before you Anna
Gray's office we wanted to welcome the
new fiction editor
I bought it for us I should have asked
you first oh my god
Christian this is Gia Matteo the
architect this location is perfect I'm
going to build you a fabulous house
please stop speaking of my husband as if
I weren't here and you may call me mrs.
gray I'll pick you up the fire
I may not be done by
we're being followed
how the hell are you Anna
Jack what do you want
so you wanna play yes sir
I made a vow to love you faithfully
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her to comfort to you one times of need
and to keep you safe first long as we
both shall live
Tirzah boy
you